e se me dissesse que estava a comida que
é produzido atualmente vai pro lixo
lutada comida 50% ainda quer dizer
atualmente vai pra baixo
é como se eu pegasse agora nessa
tangerina e tabela
sasha e para longe com muita lógica
treinar mas acontece
isto significa que 1,3 mil milhões de
toneladas de comida produzidas
atualmente nos países industrializados
vai para o lixo porém por ano é muita
coisa e sabendo de todos nós que mesmo
as pessoas que passam fome no mundo e
este valor deve aumentar todas essas
pessoas que passa fome no mundo
tanto isso tenha só consequências éticas
mas também com consequências ambientais
uma vez que estamos a gastar
desnecessariamente o nosso solo e água
energia e porque é perguntar vocês
porque toda a gente percebe que a gente
sabe que não se deve expressar comida
todos os pais e os filhos não comigo não
se brinca
mas no final das contas todos agentes
polícia e na verdade ninguém pensava
neste assunto bem existem muitas razões
para que isso aconteça
desde os metros de tecido da agricultura
que fazem exposições a forma como se
transporta e consigo guardar comida os
pados minutos que ajudam a alguns
produtos que eu não tenho muito mais
tempo e as funções que toda a gente
conhece o f5 pago 2 e depois não só
compra todo contente e no final das
contas ao fim na semana na semana e
espero estar no fundo frigorífico a
tornar-se um projeto científico
acho que toda a gente se classifique
novamente com isto anda desta marcha
esta pedra não seria escolhida por
muitas pessoas o que elas não sabem
entrou novamente é que ela por dentro
estaria assim tão boa com qualquer outra
e isto é um dos motivos que leva os
outros motivos que faz com que haja
disposição aumentar o fato da chloe
escolherem geralmente o mais bonito
feito o grande faz com que os fez com
que as grandes superfícies gigante que
na instituição sobrevive sem lista só
percebia se que no final do dia e é
fruto de alguns que não eram tão
bonitinho não era tão perfeito não
tinham a cor exata iriam e iam para o
lixo tanto condição ambiental uma série
de normas técnicas por causa do formato
por causa do calibre das frutas porque
não era tão grande como as pessoas que
estavam o tanto que nem entende do
produto o que eu tenho por certo que tem
algumas mais então estas novas festas
que atingiram imensa o o consumo de
alguns alimentos
isso fez com que 30 por cento das
plantações agrícolas em portugal e
alguns países mais fosse considerado
desperdício
tem muita coisa e estamos tão grande
hoje 7
quer dizer também que tenho mais
pequenina tomadas que têm fustigado num
influencia digamos assim tão pra mim é
vocês não seriam e somente pelo mercado
e não quer isso nem toda a gente gosta
escolhida antes ferramenta injusto mas e
assim foi e assim foi assim a fruta
feira surgiu ou surgirá esta necessidade
de trazer é que eu quero diz por isso os
agricultores diretamente o consumidor
final que não jogava há fruta nem os
golos pela preze
mas nada melhor do que administrar um
pequeno vídeo de alguns agricultores que
já tomaram a carreta fez sobre o que
acham desta ideia
eu tenho 27 anos quando comecei na
agricultura
realmente é uma fruta ou um feio mas tem
toda a qualidade pronto sua gente vai
pensar soco que é grande o que é bonito
é que é bom
estamos ainda na dilma
se eu não sei com a batata doce batata
com ela no terreno no mercado é possível
é caniné muito torta sei a jantar e por
acaso abordada em casa e fui afegão
salvaria soulwax tom ea nova data foi
mais problemas em cada vez mais alvo
[Música]
muito feia em mim sou muito bom que pode
explicar por que o exemplo seja mais
feio cérebro com um produto normalmente
fiquei serpa falta feia não ser
publicados
muita gente não for um produto mesmo
medo de alta qualidade promove a mesma
filosofia tem grande poder é todo o
planeta bola e sim é verdade
uma parte das vezes quando os portões
não conseguem escoar os produtos prontos
como este por exemplo que ele não seria
eu iria ser pela lei ficaria nos campos
o darinho animais
alguns tentam fazer compotas - na
verdade iria ser lixo e estão dizendo
que já salvou a mim é bonita é bonita e
que realmente não se percebe mesmo
porque isso iria para o lixo vem com um
grande sorriso
inicialmente desconfiados mesmo autor do
projeto falta feia eles então quer dizer
ouvir gracinhas na vida tem que ser
feita semitas evento agora dizer que
quer comprar as minhas amigas atadas
aquelas última inclina respondeu sim é
engraçado mas pelo contrário é forma de
estar também é a idéia não junto dos
consumidores pensamos em san andrés
ainda é o conselho que orientasse a de
pensarmos bem vamos enviar um e mail
primeiro aos contatos que temos apenas
com esta pergunta está uma verdadeira
quem toma café e produtos pet tivemos
quando cerca de 100 respostas numa
semana como fé eu tenho respostas
afirmativas e assim começamos a nossa
partida e não com 40 pessoas mas tem
pessoas mas percebemos que tínhamos um
grande desafio pela frente sabemos que
temos que criar fazer como comprovou que
a partida seria considerado logo lixo em
algum produto em um produto atrativo
para os consumidores que eu queria
passar a mensagem de que esta fruta
existe e logo também ela existe e é tão
boa ou melhor do que as que são
consideradas bonitas e que gente bonita
como falta feia é importante se tem de
fazer uma cooperativa de consumo coop
cooperativa de consumo fala que é juntar
novamente os consumidores nove produtos
de consumo para mudar mentalidade para
termos de novos padrões de consumo e
dizia não chega chega desses padrões de
consumo que dão só pensa nas coisas que
são bonitas
queremos mudar e assim que tentamos
criar se uma comunidade forte com a
mesma missão com a mesma paixão que é
bom nós tem pelo por combater o tipo de
cimentar esta comunidade tão forte que
vamos contar uma história
logo no início do projeto fruta feia nós
tivemos um ligeiro problema aí pelo seu
todo uma segunda feira a minha
normalmente a nossa carrinha e única
renda no momento é teu e nós ficamos bem
a luta vai vai que vai por não ser a
nossa única que a rim até o momento por
que mas também tem sido nosso maior
investimento já até à data mas tal não
aconteceu isso porque mal não associados
souberam que isso aconteceu
houve mesmo a se adaptar ou não já é
nosso ponto de entrega no teu em cima da
mesa
minhas eles não há fruta feira não vai
acabar nós vamos todos ajudar e assim
foi com a ajuda dos associados assim um
terço do valor e é produtivo colocar
esse nós montamos uma carrinha nova e
maior e fica com que até hoje já
tínhamos salvado 459 toneladas de fruta
e longe
hoje a festa foi continua com a sua
missão e sensibilizar a comunidade para
este problema e tentar que mais fruta e
como já estava estava dar aqui também
[Música]
foi apenas uma das soluções
todos nós temos um papel ativo nesta
luta
portanto eu gostaria de lembrar que
todos vocês estão aqui presentes nesta
sala que tudo o que a natureza tudo tem
formas têm tudo cor de frente tem mais
de fiança e por isso que é tão bela e é
por isso que a licença deve ser
celebrada e não desperdiçada e tanto
deixamos aqui uma questão quem é
connosco que dar uma utilidade as fés
obrigado
[Aplausos]